las autoridades mexicanas informaron el
saldo actualizado tras el operativo en
el que se detuvo a Ovidio Guzmán hijo de
Joaquín El Chapo Guzmán en conferencia
matutina en Palacio Nacional el
secretario de la defensa Luis crescencio
Sandoval dio a conocer que fueron diez
militares los que perdieron la vida
derivado del enfrentamiento con el grupo
criminal del Cártel del Pacífico entre
los diez militares muertos se encuentra
un Coronel del ejército mexicano 35
elementos más resultaron lesionados y se
encuentran recibiendo atención médica el
general informó que por parte de la
célula delictiva fueron 19 personas las
que fallecieron en este choque con las
fuerzas federales al respecto el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
dijo que lamentaba mucho que 10 miembros
del ejército y la guardia nacional hayan
perdido la vida en cumplimiento de su
deber sin embargo dijo lamentar la
pérdida de todas las vidas humanas en
este operativo en Sinaloa destacó sin
embargo que fue llevado a cabo en todo
momento con extremo cuidado para evitar
mayor daño a la población dijo que la
coordinación con las autoridades
estatales y municipales permitieron que
la situación no se tornara más dramática
hizo énfasis en que hasta el momento no
hay reporte de ningún civil inocente que
haya perdido la vida El mandatario
federal también negó que haya habido
colaboración o participación de alguna
agencia del gobierno de los Estados
Unidos dijo que si bien hay colaboración
permanente con el gobierno
estadounidense en esta ocasión todas las
decisiones Se tomaron por parte del
gabinete de seguridad del gobierno
mexicano de manera independiente
Mientras tanto en Culiacán Sinaloa las
actividades comienzan a regularizarse
paulatinamente el aeropuerto
inició reinició operaciones y también la
universidad ya retomó las clases